baseball for some is a game of lists the
top 10 power hitters of all time the
five toughest left-handers in the
national league the top three ballparks
to watch a game from the bleachers to
that end that there is another widely
discussed list that is not open for
interpretation or debate the worst
ceremonial first pitches of all time
there was Cincinnati Mayor Mark Mallory
in 2007 carly rae jepsen in 2013 and a
few notable others sprinkled in before
and after that but none had the
spectacular crash and burn impact of
what we're about to show you it was May
9th 2009 Gary Dell'Abate was about to
fulfill the dream goal of a lifetime a
passionate fan of the New York Mets the
longtime Stern Show producer was tabbed
to throw out the ceremonial first pitch
the ensuing events played out worse than
Robin Quivers most disturbing ayahuasca
nightmare
that's right Tata to see Tata tanked it
but what could have caused such a
monumental gaffe for an otherwise
functional individual who's played
countless games of catch was Gary
distracted by him Nicole bass look-alike
in the stands did he suffer delusions of
the late Araki actor finally agreeing to
the balloon stunt you know what can he
was it underdog lady who willed the
pitch to miss with her x-ray vision or
did Riley Martin's some of the powers of
the B AVI and other world to somehow
pulled the ball off its course after all
Geoff the drunks bad arm could have
delivered a better pitch let's go inside
the numbers Baba Booey style I lost my
dignity and lost the best friend the
home plate umpire lost his breath and
lost his dignity but when he gained his
wind and gained some dignity
I gained a couple of loveth I mean one
lover but I gained no friends fast
forward to today and nobody in Stern
show history has taken a bigger beating
for anything they've done not Ralph for
peeing at parties not Steve Grillo for
failing to deliver Howard's broccoli not
even Jacky to joke man for leaving the
show yet Baba Booey pop hop powers on
great thing of a video to me you can
rewind and watch it all over again
occasion just uh just you miss any
important points
Gary Dell'Abate heart of a champion arm
of an infant Baba Booey